have you ever wondered why twitch chat
always spams presi whenever Fallen hits
a
clip Brazil has blessed the Cs Community
with plenty of Portuguese quips kyota
kiso and so on so naturally one of them
had to pay respects to The Godfather
himself Fallen you see Fallen is often
referred to as Professor by the
Brazilian Community partially as a sign
of respect but mostly thanks to his many
hours spent teaching the region how to
master the beautiful game now what does
this have to do with the word presi well
when the teacher takes attendance the
students say
present
falling
falling one more back po back flank
flank
lad present present
present